The World Health
Organization, WHO for short,
is the authority for health
within the United Nations
system.
It is responsible for providing
leadership on global health
matters, shaping the
health research agenda,
setting norms and
standards, articulating
evidence-based policy options,
providing technical support
to countries, and monitoring
and assessing health trends.
WHO communicates information
about global health in order
to inform citizens, donors,
policymakers, and organizations
around the world.
Their primary publication
is World Health Report.
Each issue focuses on a specific
aspect of global health,
and includes statistics
and experts' assessments.
WHO also maintains an
open, online repository
of global health data.
WHO provides some
data visualizations,
which helps them
communicate more
effectively with the public.
As an example, the graph shows
the World Energy Consumption
during 2001 to 2003.